hello it's Jerry before the products for
awesome almost the day of the project
for awesome and I'm going crazy trying
to organize everything and making my own
project for awesome video which I have
been doing all day long
so hopefully you are already making your
video and if you have not start right
now geez
also hopefully you've glued your entire
schedule for the next two days just to
enjoy and watch and rate in comment
project for awesome videos John myself
and my wife will be spending pretty much
the entire 48 hours of the 17th and 18th
doing just that John will be on bark TV
starting 12:00 noon eastern 9 a.m. on
the west coast I have no idea other
times if you're not in America I'm sorry
I'm stupid and I'm probably gonna sleep
in a little bit and then take us deep
into the night as I'm on blogtv link in
the sidebar
we'll be there talking about whatever it
is we're doing and helping people out
with their project for awesome videos
and generally discussing the awesome I
sort of met a lot of youtubers that I
now consider to be my friends I'm
actually really really really really
really really excited about this because
last year I just remember how much fun
it was I mean it was like this huge
YouTube wide party in which people were
all hanging out in the comments and
sometimes katherine and i would be
commenting on that on different videos
and then i'd like go over I'd see
Katherine's comments somewhere else or
we didn't up suddenly commenting on the
same video as one another and have in
common conversations and I found so many
new youtubers that I didn't know about
and I really really liked their videos
we cube friends we've met in real life
since and I'm really looking forward to
having more of those experiences where I
feel like I'm part of the community or I
feel like I'm hanging out with my
friends and meeting new people and also
doing good things it's like a charity
ball except you could do it in a dark
basement alone in the nude support
certain little thumbnail thing isn't
working and I'm really sorry about the
thumbnail thing now working I think that
if you're gonna screw up my project by
changing the way that the thumbnails
work didn't you have to put me on the
front page of YouTube and you know
that's what I said to them and that's
what they did but we do have solutions
now we have new solutions that are even
better
some people have fixed the problem by
creating a green screen which is
something I don't have
then they have the project for awesome
behind them in the green screen all the
time and that is great if you have a
green screen so people have fixed it by
having a picture in picture and then
they have the project for awesome thing
in the picture in picture which I can do
blue or you can do something like this
where it's just always there and you're
talking as long as it looks like this
people are gonna know what it is
and if you want to download this file
and print it out you can if you have a
printer a link to that files in the
sidebar but the thing that will work for
everyone is have you put the project for
awesome thumbnail and the entire second
half of your video so basically if your
videos like to Natal then you have two
minutes to the into your video which you
then have to fill up with the project
for us in thumbnail and you can have
just the thumbnail or you can talk in
the background if you want to just sort
of blabber blather blabbering - laughter
make funny noises like driving with you
blather or you could put a song that you
have the rights to one of my songs from
my album will be just fine you have
permission to use one of those okay I'm
just deciding what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna write a project for awesome song
right now and then I'm gonna play it and
I'm gonna make an mp3 and I'm gonna put
that in the sidebar and it's gonna be
really long so you can have the entire
end of your video be that with the
project for awesome song if you would
like to do it that way otherwise you can
just talk or have silence as long as the
second half of your video is all project
for awesome thumbnail then you can click
on your edit video link and you can
change the thumbnail to the last
thumbnail which will be the project for
awesome thumbnail yay it's a solution I
have to write a song now fast okay I'm
gonna go finish my project for awesome
video I suggested you do the same pilot
for awesome it's better than a possum
applause ah which you will understand
once you listen to the mp3 that is now
in the sidebar yes I have already
written the song yes it was fun but it
is not good so don't expect it to be
until tomorrow